devotion is not trying to you know be in
detection tool our goal is not finding
new things our goal is to be The Driver
to fix things and basically help you
focus on your business and not about
your security
nurse just sit back relax and learn from
the leaders of today
let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
C-Tech
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Doro name the co-founder
and CEO of devotion security a cloud
application vulnerability remediation
platform devotion revolutionizes the
process of fixing risks in the new
environment of the cloud and is backed
by the load Capital partners with
participation from Angel Investors
including former Google ciso and
Amazon's head of security
previously their own service general
manager of security research at Cyber
Arc uncovering and disclosing critical
zero-day vulnerabilities to large
organizations there he founded the rcon
security conference creating a global
community of top cyber security thought
leaders researchers and decision makers
their own frequently speaks several
International cyber security conferences
and is a veteran of the elite Israel
Defense Forces 8200 unit and has a
Bachelor's of Science in computer
science
[Music]
thank you very much for being here and
you're running a really really cool
company devotion which is devotion and
that's a beautiful name and I'm really
excited to a
um and I'm really excited to talk to you
about you know the cloud World cyber
security space you know from
um from understanding that there is a
problem to mitigating and remediating
the problem and from the way that you
talk about it from finding to fixing
which which I like the the route and so
we have a lot to to talk in these 20
minutes and well we'll see what we can
get through and so first of all thank
you very very much for being here Duron
tell me a little bit about your own
relationship with cyber security and
then we'll dive into devotion
so it started when I was very very young
and I think that Curiosity was the the
thing that uh you know moved me uh I
remember when I was 13 there's the bar
mitzvah you know when my father and he
knows that I like he knew that like a
computer and stuff so he bought me a new
computer
and I was very curious to see okay what
can I do with it so I started playing
with it overclocking it and this
computer was very expensive I'm talking
about like uh
10K million dollars backluck in the time
it's a lot of money and but after a week
or something I just buried it just
totally
um
so uh so it started when I was very
young my father told me he I was you
know assuming that he will be pissed you
know he just bought me the computer I
just ruined but he came with to me and
said
I trust you I know you were learning
from it and just bought me like a very
cheap computer and comparing to the old
one uh and I stayed with it till I was
18 but I was learning so much with this
and I think curiosity always you know
moved me to everywhere that I went and I
started doing uh uh you know like a
hacking stuff when I was kid and I later
on joined to A200
um
as I know that you also uh remember over
there and then uh hey just excited my
career in the startup company that got
acquired by cyber and then I was a group
manager of research for almost five
years uh
over at the Privileges to to privilege
to work with great great people at Cyber
and doing a lot of good and you know
presenting around the world and got a
chance to work and develop
great people
now to devotion so they select the
journey
I love it well if you're looking at
um you know your experience of the cyber
world is is not new
um and you've experienced the cyber
world in quite a few different mediums
from from different sides of the
spectrum as well we'll say from both
sides of the battlefield and
um and if you're looking at when you
approach the devotion from an
entrepreneur's perspective obviously
you're thinking about okay what am I
going to be devoting the next several
years to and and creating something
that's that's not that's not existing
yet how are you seeing the cyber world
the different opportunities there that
led to your conviction on what devotion
is doing today
so most of the stories start with I had
a vision you know had a passion and I
wanted to do it like it's mostly a
startup right I don't need to tell you
baby you hear a lot of people uh I think
mine was a very different uh in a way I
I was working for cyberk for five years
I had a great time I was doing
Innovation I was doing m a i was working
with the entire company and I love it
but I just for myself it was coffee time
and I said I need time to myself I
didn't know that I'm going to start a
company I just I need time to think what
I want to do and I went to Greece really
it's a you know all my stories are real
but it's a real story and uh and I I
learned I learned just chess there over
there like 10 days I went I cleaned my
my mind they were no one actually
traveled because of kovid and
I I remember that I used to talk to a
lot of uh you know systems and and
security teams around the Beloved when I
also traveled uh to uh events uh also
through cyber and
and I think it got me like I talked to
people I didn't know what I'm gonna do
but they actually we are one-sided to
talk and started talking to more and
more people I understood that this is
what I want to do because and I think
this is like the main thing that I was
curious about
it's interesting how I can build
something like that like this it draw
like this is that was the driver for me
because I I didn't know exactly that
this is the right solution that I want
to build
I just wanna
know if I can solve this problem for all
these people so I try to to find a
common sense and when I found this a
common sense for all of them I was doing
validation I think more than I made more
than 50 calls
two different personas around the globe
and I realized that and then I realized
I want to do it so it I didn't have a
vision but I just started with a
something that I read you know it's AWS
and Amazon the big company they talk
about customer Obsession yeah and yep
and it's uh and I started like thinking
about it on the back of my head and
started to talk to people and I
understood that if I'll come with the
idea
um probably I won't you know I want to
find the right uh problem for uh myself
I need to to ask them and this is what I
did and and it wasn't like you know I
did I asked them like what are your
problems we just talked and it just uh
happened
incredible okay so let's dive into the
the problem space
um that you
that that you discovered and then a
little bit about how you started
executing on it in in a world where we
have an abundance of cyber attacks and
abundance of Cyber Solutions yet it
seems like there's still a gap or a
vacuum that you realize that exists that
can be very beneficial for these
security teams
exactly so when I talk to this Security
Guys and csos they told me listen I
don't need another security tool in the
cloud I I have I have enough uh scanners
that scans my containers my
vulnerabilities my misconfiguration my
apis I don't need something else what
what do I need really from you is help
me solve these issues help me fix them
and the problem in the cloud is is is
that you have a bunch of things so that
you don't know it's the same thing
you're getting from so many you know
different vectors and you need to
understand exactly who is the right
person to solve it and what you need to
do and this is basically requires a lot
of time from security teams today to do
the context the research find the right
time and validate it actually being
solved so the entire mediation in the
cloud is something that is pretty new to
the world everyone was very focused on
okay let's get visibility first which
makes sense like every other industry
you want to make visibility and you want
to be able to know what are your
problems but now that the world is
coming into uh to a point where
you have a huge backlog and backlog
means attack surface in these days so we
are helping companies today to solve
much faster security issues and fight
the right team the right person to to do
that
cross across teams from security to
develops to Developers
I love it and and how does that actually
happen from your perspective so you're
coming in with the background and your
understanding so how do you even get
started in in understanding what are the
different ways in which I can help these
teams make sense of all these problems
and solutions and mitigating them
so it took time because every every
company Works differently today there is
no standard you know how to fix things
in the cloud vulnerabilities in the
cloud misconfiguration
Etc so it took time I think it's like a
private Market fit you are having like
an idea of okay this is what I'm going
to do I'm going to connect to these you
know security feed I'm going to connect
to your cloud or to connect to your uh
development uh pipelines and I'm trying
to you know bring uh entire workflow you
know from business are the cloud Rams
and these are the the radiation step
that you need to take with this guy so
the entire Journey takes time to
understand exactly how everyone works
and what works for everyone and and what
integration you need to do what death
you need to go into the integration so
it's a lot of you know you go and and
also I think it's the same today we
inventing something that does not exist
really right so there is nothing that
like running for five years that people
doing it and you know that you know to
do one two three we are also very
careful with the with the market and
very patient and we see how where it
goes uh what solution out there what we
can bring into the solution how
developers and devops actually you know
have the responsibility actually shifted
between them and security and we learn
it and we want to basically at the end
of the day fit to these processes and in
the future also educate exactly how it
needs to be done and save a lot of time
automate a lot of Remediation in the
club
so talk to me about the founding of this
company what were yours as a serial
entrepreneurialism is as an executive
already in the cyberspace with a lot of
hands-on experience what were the
different things that you took with you
as you founded devotion that you know
and that that you say okay wow these
were you know this was a more I guess
mature way of looking at things that
that if I was looking at my first time
as an entrepreneur I may not have even
realized back then
so so the first startup that I worked
with you know the first one after the
Harvest service was uh was uh I was the
employee number 10 or something like
that so I learned a lot and also had the
privilege to to you know migrate or
emerge into cyborg so I felt and I also
took a lot from the founders of cyberton
of the the old startup I took so many
things and I also felt it as an employee
how it feels to you know work in a small
company and being you know emerging to a
big company and I think this is gave me
a perspective again also I I had the
privilege to manage more than 20 people
at Cyber so I
I think it gave me a lot of perspective
on how employee at Cyber like at a small
company how he feels what he looks for
what is the you know right communication
that you need to build in a small
company which is very very different
than you know corporate
um so I took these tools that I took
also from the founders and and I took so
many and I don't know they even you know
listened to it I never told them you
know what what one thing I can say that
they invested in the company so they've
been making us uh you know
in the the vaccines but I took so many
and and I'm very happy that uh and I
learned and you know I take it a lot I
took a lot of little things but I still
learned a lot during the journey and I
think being a CEO in in a general no
matter of speaking and every CEO can I
feel a resonate I think you can resonate
with that that you don't you don't start
as a CEO and CEO role is changing all
the time and it's actually a journey
that you always do different stuff in
different phases of the startup so it's
a very exciting uh exciting role what is
the part of the role that you're most
excited about from your perspective
well uh first of all uh you do
everything as a you know the CEO from
the first moment you do uh marketing
you're doing sales you're doing product
you're doing
um recruitment you do everything so I
I think this is something that you know
how many times in your life you will run
sales or you will you know hire PP cells
you I've never been of episodes I've
never worked as a salesperson so how can
I know who's the right Wiki said so it's
a lot of you know learning you you if
you were I I think if you were doing
your
if you are willing to get help from
people and listen to them you will make
a better decisions so we use we have
more than 21 engine investors
in our company so every one of them
bringing uh different kind of skills or
background and we use this in order to
you know validate better our candidates
and making decisions
Etc so I I think that what I like the
most is being in the center
uh and and actually build every other
operation in the company from scratch
and let it grow really so it's uh it's
really amazing yeah that's really really
cool so let's dive in just a little bit
into security teams and and the way that
today you're offering them your your
your solution tell me a little bit about
their behavior and how you see devotion
as a part of their daily tools of
mitigation
yeah so today they're consuming
many events from different tools it
doesn't help to have you know they don't
have to need to have many Tools in order
to have radiation gaps but in order to
see a full picture of okay what are my
risks in the cloud they need to jump
from different kind of uh dashboards and
different kind of tools some of them
cover the code the assets some of them
cover the runtime assets some of them
cover the cloud environment so it's it's
it's many layers within the application
and we suggest to bring everything into
one place one to get visibility because
every one of them giving you visibility
and we are basically unified the thing
and help you bridge the gap between
specific security tools but also we are
consolidating aggregating you're helping
you focus on what's important so this is
like the first phase of of of devotion
journey in security teams let's say
daily basis work with with the with the
solution they don't need to jump they
don't need to talk to their developers
about okay what are the threats that we
got from sneak we don't need to jump
into a cloud rail in in or other Cloud
native security tools and understand
what are the feeds that they got from
there they don't need to jump to API or
kubernetes security platform to
understand what are the risk they get
everything in a very wide context and we
help them to drive remediation with the
right owners and with the right action
items they need to take with with the
team so as we say today is something
that you start with the backlog of today
devotion help you too said okay this is
on my five top things that I need to do
today and we are helping you to to to do
that
um so I think this is like the Journey
of devotion tell you exactly what's most
important right now for your
applications and these are the things
that you need to do with your developers
and devops and we're trying to automate
as much as we can with this process so
people will you know get their hands
when they must and whether or not must
we can you know open automatically
tickets PRS Etc so we can drive a
mediation without the human interpretion
International incredible and if you're
looking at the vision of devotion in in
this world what what is the vision that
you're setting out for this company long
term
so there are so many there are so many
vectors you know when you start a
company you can say wow I can I can
definitely be the you know the seam for
the cloud you know being one place that
you have everything in your Cloud
anywhere driving remediation to the
right teams
um
it's very hard to tell
um and I'm I'm very like no
back to Earth in a way there are so many
vectors that we can take this company
right now we're working very closely
with the with security companies in the
cloud and in the code scanning and other
that we get through partnership with
them and I think our
driver and our goal is to build a lot of
relationship with the ecosystem so we
will be able to to I think it's a it's a
team play today uh in security uh you
always have new tools you always have
consolidation between tools and it
happens a lot between Technologies but
we have to remember that it's always you
always have something new that's coming
up and we want to be on top of
everything building great communication
so we'll be able also to grow as the
market grow and the needs grow for the
for the customer
um
I mean I like I think we you know the
best way to look at a market is to see
what happened on other markets and say
okay this is how it behaves and so for
example when you fix your
vulnerabilities in not in the cloud in
old-fashioned kind of uh you know
on-premise repositories it's still a
pain it's still attained so it never
ends and I think Remediation in the
cloud is uh is the art and since
everyone is still moving to the cloud
there are some organizations that just
started moving to the cloud the journey
is very long and we're here to you know
to to educate exactly how to fix and to
work with everyone and with every
technology you know today you have
kubernetes tomorrow you can have
something different but for devotion it
doesn't matter because devotion is not
trying to you know be in detection tool
our goal is not finding new things our
goal is to be The Driver to fix things
and basically help you focus on your
business and not about your security
I love it and Dawn it sounds like such a
such a cool Journey that you're on from
being so Hands-On to experiencing you
know the startup space and then uh and
and growing within a large company to a
really uh phenomenal role and obviously
now you know the entrepreneurial role as
a CEO changing every day learning and
harnessing from the insights of 21
incredible investors and I'm sure that
you have an even larger community that
are that are supporting you and guiding
you and with bringing the humility and
the humbleness of knowing that you're
not that you don't know everything and
um that makes sense obviously but but
coming with that humility to leverage on
the great expertise and experience of
others and sounds like just an awesome
journey of curiosity which sounds to me
like and what you mentioned started very
young so thank you very very much for
your time and for your energy best of
luck with devotion I can't wait to to
continue and you know following from the
side and sharing from the side and thank
you very much
thank you thank you very much
[Music]